[Music]
hi everyone my name is Samir Kataria and
I'm an engineer on the Android team I
work on architecture components and
today I want to talk to you about a new
library we have called work manager and
background processing in general on
Android so let's talk about background
processing in 2018 what are we trying to
do these days just this morning I was
trying to send a picture of my lovely
wife and my beautiful son to the rest of
my family so that's an example of
background processing we're also sending
logs syncing data processing that data
all of this work is being done in the
background and on Android there's a lot
of different ways you can do this work
here's a lot of them you can do things
on threats and executors using job
scheduler alarmmanager
async tasks etc which one should you use
and when should you use it meanwhile
Android also has a lot of battery
optimizations that we've introduced over
the last few years
for example the introduced doze mode in
marshmallow if you've been following
Android P we've had app standby buckets
in Oreo we restricted background apps
background services so all of these
things have to be taken care of as a
developer and finally we always have to
worry about backwards compatibility so
if you want to reach 90% of Android
devices you want to at least have a min
SDK of KitKat so given all of this what
tools you use and when do you use them
and the trick behind this is that you
have to look at the types of background
work that you're doing I like to split
this up into two axes the vertical axis
here is the timing of the work does the
work need to be done right when it's
specified or can it wait for a little
bit so that if your app and your device
enters doze mode you can still do it
after that also on the horizontal axis
here how important is the work does the
work only need to be done while your
in the foreground or does it absolutely
need to be done at some point so for
example if you're taking a bitmap and
you decide that you want to extract a
color from it and update your UI with it
that's an example of foreground only
work you don't care about it once the
user hits home or back that work is
irrelevant meanwhile if you're sending
logs you always want that to happen
that's an example of guaranteed
execution so for things that are best
effort you really want to use things
like thread pools rxjava or coroutines
for things that require exact timing and
guaranteed execution you want to use a
foreground service so an example of this
would be that you're the user hits a
button and you want to process a
transaction and update the UI and the
state of the app based on that that
really needs a foreground service that
needs to happen right then your app
cannot be killed by the system while
that's happening this fourth category is
very interesting so you want guaranteed
execution but you're okay if it happens
later or doze mode can kick in and
there's a variety of ways to solve it on
your API as you'll use job scheduler if
you want to go a little further back you
can use firebase job dispatcher to do
that and if you don't have Google Play
services you'll probably end up using
alarm manager and broadcast receivers
and if you want to do target all of
those things well you'll use some mix of
these four things and that's a lot of
API is a lot of work to be done work
manager falls here it's guaranteed
execution that's deferral it's a work
manager let's talk a little bit about
its features I just mentioned guarantee
execution is also constrained aware so
if I want to upload that photo that I
talked about I only want to do it when I
have a network that's the constraint
it's also respectful of the system
background restrictions so if your app
is in doze mode it won't execute it
won't wake up your phone just to do this
work it's backwards compatible with or
without Google Play services the API is
variable so if you have in cute some
work you can actually check what is it
state is it running
now it has it succeeded or failed these
are things that you can find out with
work manager it's also chainable so you
can create drafts of work so you can
have work a depending on work B and C
which in turn depends on work D also
work managers optimistic so this means
that we will try to execute that work in
your process as soon as the constraints
are met without actually needing job
scheduler to intervene or call you out
and wake you up
it doesn't wait for job scheduler to
batch at work if your process is up and
running already so let's talk about a
little bit of the basics and talk
through the code so I just described the
example I want to upload that photo so
how would I do that using work manager
let's talk about the core classes
there's the worker class this is the
class that does the work this is where
you will write most of your business
logic and there's a work request class
which comes in two flavors one type work
requests or things that just need to be
done once in periodic work requests for
recurring work and these will both take
a worker I'll show you just now so
here's my upload photo worker it extends
the worker class and it overrides the do
work method this is the method that will
run in the background will take care of
that on the background thread you don't
need to put it in a background thread so
you simply do your work so in this case
we're off with the photo synchronously
and we return our results so in this
case let's say we succeeded and the
worker resulting I'm here has three
values success and failure which are
fairly obvious and retry which says I
encountered a transient error let's say
that the device lost network connection
in the middle so retry me after a little
bit with some back off so now that I
have this I can create a one-time work
request using the upload photo worker
and then I can in queue it using work
manager get instance in queue so soon
after this isn't cute it'll start
running you'll upload your photo but I
just talked about this what if you lose
connectivity in the middle of this or
even before it is what if you never had
connectivity you actually want to use
constraints in this case
so an example of the constraint here you
want to use is you make a constraints
builder and you say set required network
pipe to be connected so you need a
connected network connection you built
it and you also set the constraints on
the request that you just built so by
simply doing this and then in queueing
it you make sure that this work only
runs when your network is connected so
let's say we want to observe this work
now that we've done it so I want to show
a spinner while this work is executing
and then I want to hide the spinner when
it's done how would I do that
so as I said I'll in queue this request
and then I can say gets satisfy ID on
work manager using the request ID so
each request has an ID and this returns
a live data out the work status if you
guys remember architecture components
live data is a life cycle aware
observable so now you can just hook it
to that observable and you can say when
that work is finished hide that progress
bar so what is this work status object
that you were looking at at the live
data it has an ID this is the same ID as
a request and it has a state the state
is this the current state of execution
there's six values here in cute running
succeeded or failed blocked and canceled
and we'll talk about their last two
later so let's move a step up in concept
here let's talk about chaining work so I
promised that you can actually make
directed acyclic graphs of work how
would you do that
let's say this is my problem now I'm
uploading a video it's a huge video I
want to compress it first then upload it
so these are both eligible for
background work because they're time
intensive things so let's say I have two
workers compressed photo worker and
upload photo worker they're both defined
to do the things that I just said so you
can make work request from them and you
can say work manager begin with
compressed work then upload work and in
queue it so this ensures that compressed
work executes first and once it's
successful
then upload work goes and if you were to
write this out because that was a very
fluent way of writing it what happens
behind the scenes here is that begin
with returns of work continuation and a
work continuation has a method called
then that also returns of or
continuation a different one so you're
using that to create that's fluent API
so you can actually use these work
continuations and pass them around if
you want
etc so let's say that I'm uploading
multiple photos I take lots of photos no
one takes only just one photo of their
child so how would I upload all of these
in parallel well so let's say I've got
work requests for all of them I can
literally just say dot and queue and put
all of them there is a more arc so you
can pass more than one thing there and
these are all at you eligible for
running in parallel they may not
actually run in parallel depending on
your device and the executor being used
in all of that but they could be so
let's choose an even more complex
example now you want to filter your
photos so you want to apply some kind of
I don't know grayscale filter or sepia
filter to them then you want to compress
them then you want to upload them how
would you do this work manager makes it
very simple so first you say begin wit
you do all the filter works in parallel
after those have all completed
successfully then you do your
compression work and after those have
completed that is completed successfully
then you do your upload work and don't
forget to in to you at the end so we've
talked about all of that but there's the
key concept that I want to cover that's
very much related to chaining this is
inputs and outputs so let's talk about
this problem that I have here it's a
MapReduce and it's really a good way of
explaining on MapReduce is to give an
example
I love reading I've loved reading
Sherlock Holmes novels since I was a kid
and the other day I was thinking well
Arthur Conan Doyle has a very specific
way of writing what are the top ten
words he uses in his books well how
would I figure that out I would go
through each book I would count the
occurrence of each
word and then I would combine all of
that data and sort sorted so that I
would find the top 10 of those this is a
distributed problem that we could call a
MapReduce and for inputs and outputs the
common unit of operation here is a data
the data is a simple class that's a key
value map under the hood the keys are
strings the values are primitives and
strings and the array versions of each
so this is kind of like a bundle or a
parcel ball but it's it's own thing
it's serializable by work manager and we
limited to 10 kilobytes in size and I'll
go more more into that part later so how
do we create a data so in Kotlin you can
make a map very easily so in this case
we're mapping the key file name to the
value a study in scarlet text that's the
novel that I'm gonna look at and I'll
convert it to a work data so this is a
data object and once I create my work
request builder I can set the input data
on it so this is the input data of that
map and I pass it along so inside my
worker I can actually retrieve this
input data by just calling the get input
data method and from that I can get the
string for the file names and now I have
the file name and I can say count all
the world occurrences in this file name
that's some method that I've written
somewhere else and I can return my
success but you don't want to do just
that you actually want to also have
outputs right now you've done all this
work it should do something there should
be an output for it so let's say that
method that we have returns a map of
words to their occurrences we can
convert that map to a work data and we
can call a method call set output data
that sets this data so get input data
set out the data so the key observation
that you need to know here is that a
workers outputs become the inputs for
its children so what happens it's the
fine top ten words worker which goes
next
it's input data is coming from the
previous worker so in this case you can
pass the data all the way through find
the top ten words and return out so the
data flow for one book becomes like this
I'll count all the world occurrences in
that book I'll pass it to define top ten
words worker
it'll its input data will be whatever I
pass through and it'll do the sorting or
whatever it needs to do but here's a
really tricky thing what happens when
you have multiple books what's the input
for the fine top ten words worker you're
passing multiple pieces of data but I've
only been able to get one input data
what happens to the rest of them or how
do they combine for this you want to
look at input mergers so an input merger
is a class that combines data from
multiple sources into one data object
and we provide two implementations out
of the box overriding input merger which
is the default and array creating input
merger you can also create your own but
let's talk about these two first or
writing input mergers so we have two
data objects here each with their own
keys and values
what does overwriting input merger do it
first takes the first piece of data and
it just puts everything in a new data
object so it's an exact copy of this
then it takes a second piece of data and
it copies it over so overwriting
anything that's the same key so in this
case the name Alice becomes Bob and the
age of 30 becomes three days note that
I'd change type so a number became a
string here the scores key was new so I
just got added note that if we did this
in Reverse instead of Bob you wouldn't
have Alice as the final output so this
is something a little tricky you want to
make sure that overriding input merger
is the right tool for the job but it is
very simple
what about array creating input merger
this is the one that actually takes care
of those collision case so in this case
let's go just keep I keep the name
becomes an array of Alice and Bob color
becomes a singleton array of blue
it's only defined in one of them scores
notice that there's one integer and one
array of integers these combined and
they just concatenate together order is
not specified but all the values come
through what happens for age so if
there's an in an integer and there's a
string this is an exception we do accept
expect it to be the same basic value
type so let's go back to that example I
was telling you about Sherlock Holmes
implicitly there's an input merger
before the stage so we combine all of
that data and which input merger do we
want to use so we want to we don't want
to throw away any of this calculation
that we've done so we actually want to
use an array creating a quick merchant
which preserves all of the data and gets
it through so how do we do that well we
just say set input merger on the request
builder of the pine top ten words so it
merges they die using an array creating
input merger so you say begin with the
count words Workers then do the pine top
ten words worker and then thank you so
for example if the first book had ten
instances of the word Sherlock five of
Watson and thirty of elementary and the
second one had 12 15 and five you would
get arrays like this Sherlock would be
1012 Watson would be 515 Elementary
would be 35 so in your five top ten
words worker you would sum all of that
up sort them find the top ten and that's
your output and I just said that's our
outlet right so you can actually observe
the output in your work status using
that live data so you can actually get
that output data so that's super useful
because you can display it in your UI
how do you cancel work so I just decided
to send up a picture but I'm like wait a
sec this is not the picture I meant to
send up how do you cancel that upload
very simple you just say cancel work by
ID but do note that cancellation is
best-effort so the work may have already
finished these are all asynchronous
things they may be happening in the
background before you've had a chance to
that canceled work it may already be
running or finished so it's best effort
okay so let's talk a little bit more
about tags and tags are solving this
problem IDs that I just told you about
are Auto generated they're not human
readable so there are actually uu IDs
under the hood and you can't really
understand them they're not useful for
debugging if you log them they're not
gonna make sense what kind of work was
running I don't know it's just some big
number I don't know what that is tags
solve this issue tags are a readable way
to identify your work so tags are
developer specified strings by you and
each work requests can have zero or more
tags you can query and cancel work by
tag let's look at an example so I used
to work on the G+ team here and the G+
app supports multi login so you can have
multiple users logged in at the same
time and each of those users could be
doing several kinds of background work
you could be getting favorites you could
be getting preferences so if you have
three users logged in on your phone and
they're doing two kinds of work you have
six things happening how do you identify
what you're looking at it at any given
time well you can use tags so for
example in this work request builder you
can add tags to say this is user one and
this is the get favorites operation so
now you can actually identify that work
and if you wanted to look at the
statuses you could say give me all of
the work for use in one and this will
return a list of work statuses as a live
data because each tag can correspond to
more than one work request so this is a
list of work statuses similarly you can
also cancel all work by tag cancellation
is best-effort again but you can cancel
all of one particular kind of work in
this case tags are also useful for a
couple of other reasons tags namespace
your type of work as I just told you
like you can have tags for the kinds of
operations you're doing get favorites
get
preferences etc but they also namespace
libraries and modules so here a library
owner or a module owner you should
always tag your work so you can get it
later let's say that you have a library
and you move to a new version of that
library in your app maybe you want to
cancel all the work you had you can
cancel all work by your tag so always
use tags when you are using a library
and work status also has tags available
in it so if you're ever looking at a
work status you can get the tags for
that work and see what what you yourself
called it in the past when you include
it one more thing I wanted to talk about
is unique work so unique work solves a
few different problems but one of the
common ones that almost every app has is
syncing you want to sync when you first
launch the app you want to sync maybe
every 12 to 24 hours to get the freshest
data and you may also want to sync when
your language changes maybe you have a
version of your data in a different
language so you want to sync at that
point too so you're doing all this
thinking but you really only want one
sync active at a time you don't want
four sync operations running which one's
the right one which one wins you don't
know you just want one unique word can
solve this so it is each a chain of work
can be given a unique name you can in
cue query and cancel using that name and
there can only be one chain of work with
that name let's take a look at that sync
example so if I say begin unique work
with my name let's say sync in this case
and the next argument is the what I call
the existing work policy so if there is
work with this name sync what should I
do with it in this case I say keeping I
want to keep the existing work ignore
what I'm doing right now the next
argument is actually your work requests
in this case of sync request when you
into it so if there's work with the name
think already in flight it will keep
that if there isn't it will link you
this and exit
so this is how you do dupe your sinks so
here at Google we love chat apps and
maybe you're updating your chat status
so you want to say I'm bored and then 10
seconds later I'm watching TV then I'm
bored again okay I'm going to sleep and
you're in a bad network connection state
you have bad Wi-Fi and maybe the first
thing hasn't gone through when you type
your second chat status update and
really the second one should win and the
third one should win over that so you
want to make sure that the last one wins
how would you solve this here's a simple
function you don't even you need to read
the rest of it it's the last line that I
want you to care about which is begin
unique work it's your name is update
status and you choose a replace option
replace cancels and deletes any existing
in flight operations off that name so
the last one always does want in this
case if you have to update chat status
calls the last one will win and finally
I love music I love the Foo Fighters I
was building a playlist the other day
with all their songs there's a lot of
songs there's like 150 or 200 songs and
I was doing all of this I was adding a
song I was shuffling two songs around I
was moving something to the bottom of
the list I was deleting a song because I
had it already somewhere else these are
all things that I want to do using work
manager but how would I do that these
things all have to execute in order and
so since the order is important we
provide the ability to use the append
existing work policy that says do this
work at the end of the list of update
playlist operations so just append this
to the end of this thing so everything
else must successfully execute before
this execute so you can add operations
to the end so existing work policy as a
summary there's three types keep replace
and append a few notes about periodic
work it works very similarly to
everything you've seen so far just a
couple notes on it so the minimum period
length is the same as job scheduler it
is four
fifteen minutes it is still subject to
doze mode and OS background restrictions
just like any of the other work we've
talked about it can't be chained and it
can't have initial delays and we think
that that just sort of makes good API
sense that it's much more reasonable to
think of it in those terms all right so
we've talked a lot about code let's uh
let's talk about how it all works under
the hood so you've got at work you in
queue it we store it in our database
what happens after that well if the work
is eligible for execution we just send
it to the executor right away by the way
this executor you can actually specify
it but we do provide one that's default
but let's say that your process gets
killed well what happens then how does
it get woken up and how does this work
run again so if you're on API 23 plus we
send it to job scheduler as well and job
scheduler invokes an IPC wakes up your
process it goes to the same executor and
that's where it runs if it's an older
device and you use firebase job
dispatcher and user optional dependency
we can send it to firebase job
dispatcher same thing invokes an IPC
runs it on that executor what if you
don't have that or you're not using a
Google Play services device so you're
using something else we have an
accustomed alarm manager and broadcast
receiver implementation and the same
thing uses an IPC wakes up your app when
the time is right and runs the job a
couple implementation details so job
scheduler and firebase job dispatcher
through Google Play services they prove
they provide central load balancing
mechanism for executions so if every app
on your device is trying to run jobs
their load balance them they'll make
sure that like you're not running too
much work on your device and burning up
your battery the alarmmanager
implementation that we have
unfortunately can't do that because it's
only aware of your own app of course
your concepts like content URI triggers
idle doze mode etc are only available at
the API level
introduce that so those methods will be
marked with requires API the appropriate
API level we take care of obtaining
wakelocks when necessary so especially
this is true for the alarmmanager
implementation don't take wakelocks in
your workers you don't need to do that
we take care of it for you finally let's
talk a little bit about testing you want
to test this app we provide a testing
library it has a synchronous executor
use work manager as normal to in queue
your request and we provide a class
called test driver which executes sync
you'd work that has constraints so we
can just pretend that the constraints
been met periodic and initial delay
triggers are coming soon we don't have
them yet so if you wanted to look at the
code for it
you can initialize the test work manager
you can get the test driver create and
in queue your work as you normally would
with a constraint in this case and we
can tell the test driver hey all
constraints are met for this work your
work executes at that point
synchronously and you can verify the
state of your app and make sure that
everything's right I also want to talk a
little bit about best practices before I
end here it's very important to know
when to use work manager work manager is
for tasks that can survive process debts
it can even wake up your app and your
apps process to do the work so for
example it's ok when you want to use it
to upload media to a server it's also ok
when you part-1 a parse data and store
it in your database it's not ok for that
example I gave earlier you're extracting
the palette color from an image and
updating an image view with it because
that's for gran only work it's also not
okay when you're parsing data and just
updating the contents of a view because
you could switch screens you could go in
the background it's not work that needs
to use work manager it doesn't need to
survive processed at all so it's not ok
to process payment transactions in it if
they care about timing right then so if
you click buy and you want to update the
state of the app that really needs
something else so that last one needs a
four
and service the other two may just use
thread pools or rx also work manager is
not your data store instances of data
are limited to 10 kilobytes each when
serialized so data is really meant for
like intermediate transportation of
information you can put file your eyes
or keys to other databases in there if
you want you can put simple information
to update your UI if you want to use a
full data store I would recommend using
room it would be very happy that I'm
saying this it's an awesome database
finally be opportunistic with your work
so here's a filter compress upload
example again the reason that these are
not just one big job is because they all
have just different constraints so they
can execute at different times let's say
I'm getting on an airplane and I'm
uploading a bunch of images and and
running this chain of work while I go
into airplane mode maybe I don't have
network for the next 12 hours because
I'm flying across the world well the
other work can still execute and it
should so if you architect like this you
can't do that this also by the way it
makes their code a little bit more
testable because you can write a test
for filtering that isn't conflated with
compression and upload alright and I
want to talk about a few next steps for
you if you need to reach us and talk to
us about work manager we are in the
Android sandbox just behind us I think
over here diandra comm / arch / work
that's more information on the official
developer website about work manager
these are all the Gradle dependencies
the first ones are required one the
second one is if you use firebase job
dispatcher also include that there's a
testing library and of course we have
Goblin extensions as well work manager
is part of the architecture components
in Android jetpack and we have a bunch
of talks here tomorrow navigation
controller 8:30 a.m. hope you guys make
it there
and thanks for being part of this talk
we look forward to hearing back from you
soon thank you
[Music]